[Music]
social media is flipping out over the
Spanish sci-fi horror flick the platform
which secured its stateside release
through Netflix the film is being called
a perfect parable for our troubled times
not to mention a taut unblinking
merciless thriller in recent times
Netflix has been regularly shouldering
its way into the national spotlight with
the kind of original content that seems
specifically calibrated to grab the
eyeballs of millions of people all at
once
first on February 13th there was love is
blind an unapologetically melodramatic
reality series focused on a batch of
couples who date court and make the
decision as to whether or not to get
married without ever actually you know
seeing each other then on March 20th
there was Tiger king an original
docu-series focused on private zoo owner
Joe exotic and a cast have been saying
caricatures all of whom are in probably
real people when Joe rented a helicopter
Gabriel and a lot of really bad at is
now there's the platform which as of the
making of this video has earned an 82%
fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes the show
has viewers in disbelief over how
ridiculously timely it is not to mention
well-crafted well acted and relentlessly
disturbing American audiences aren't
likely to recognize much of the cast but
that will only land even more gritty
authenticity to the proceedings so what
is the platform all about anyway the
movie centers on goring a resident of
the pit which is a prison constructed
like a tower of indeterminate height
each level has massive holes in its
floor and ceiling through which the
titular platform descends every day on
this platform is enough food for all of
the pits prisoners but the inmates near
the top are free to take as much food as
they want often not leaving enough or
any at all for those on the lower levels
throughout the film goring binds himself
assigned to different levels of the pit
sharing space with some unsettling
roommates also figuring heavily into the
movies increasingly alarming narrative a
mysterious woman who rides the platform
searching the pits various levels for
her child
of course Goran is eventually confronted
with violence cannibalism and other
unspeakable situations all while trying
to figure out just how far down the
levels go and attempting to get the
prisoners to cooperate rather than
working against each other the bill
sports a bizarre final revealed that
will leave you scratching your head and
wondering just what kind of message we
should be sending to those on the top
levels of our own medical
uncle Pitts it's easy to view the
platform as an allegory for class
warfare an issue which has gained more
and more political prominence over the
course of the last decade or so on its
surface it can also be seen as a simple
stark message things could be a whole
lot worse this seems to be the takeaway
for several Twitterers including hans
gruber who wrote with tongue planted
firmly in cheek if you want to watch a
grim film about being confined in a
nightmare prison without food I suggest
watching the platform on Netflix it's
pretty good user Kate Valdez was a
little more succinct writing crazy food
will never be the same again user cat
declawed posted a strong recommendation
along with an equally strong warning
just finished watching the platform on
Netflix and I'm wrecked and I need to
lie down you know it's a good one when
it's that impactful it was extreme and
hard to watch but has a relevant message
apt in these desperate times twelve out
of ten highly recommended user Stefan
she echoed the sentiment I can't believe
the platform was only an hour and 35
minutes it felt like two to three hours
simply because of how heavy gruesome
murky and painful it is to watch it was
torture and I couldn't blink for fear
that I would miss a second the platform
is strong stuff indeed but for fans of
jolting horror it should be a welcome
escape a gory nerve wrenching really
messed up escape check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite horror
flicks are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you
[Music]